i want it i got it i don't want a mirror
i've got it i don't want it i want it
i don't want it i don't wanna make it
i love that sound i want it
oh
why do i love watching things get
smushed in slow motion
especially at the end when it does that
little spoof
[Music]
oh this looks like a spider-man thing
i don't know if that's the optimal way
of taking them off i'm not a cupping
expert
do i think it works i'm gonna assume
that there's
a decent amount of it that is a placebo
effect but there's also probably some
benefit
in terms of distracting you from the
pain also increasing circulation to the
fascia
and the tissues in that area i have had
one hour of sleep
one brownie two shots of espresso
and i am ready to either fight god or
die trying i went through
all of med school and residency without
really drinking coffee
now i am addicted and i am on the
caffeine kick by the way if you haven't
seen bianca and sarah on the channel
you need to we played would you rather
this video is for dr mike and dr mike
only so if you're not dr mike
keep scrolling please explain to me what
the actual purpose of the uvula is other
than being a very fancy squishy
chandelier for the back of my facial
cavity
the little boxing bag that you're
referring to in the back of your throat
also known as the palatine uvula
is really put there in order to prevent
liquids and foods from entering our
nasal cavities
and it lubricates the throat and one of
the most important things in case you
choke it serves as your gag reflex you
all want to know how to get a tan super
fast
use some pam organical no original
this is after 30 minutes i'll get back
to y'all in an hour
and this is after an hour oh why
you are not a chicken in a pot do not
use pam
to cook yourself in all seriousness if
you put oil
you're literally magnifying the rays
that cause skin
cancer
[Music]
patients now are bringing in printouts
of what they read online about their
condition or potential condition
while a lot of the stuff you find online
is not accurate it fosters a good
conversation so you understand how a
doctor's mind works i'm all for it as
long as you bring it in
and not just self-treat
[Music]
i am literally falling apart i had eye
surgery my teeth are falling apart
i had some like abnormal vein on my face
i had my shoulder injected because i had
ac
joint arthropathy my low back has been
acting up i can't stand up without
making sound effects because everything
is just
achy and sore if i have like three
glasses of alcohol all of a sudden i
can't function the next day
psy hi it's babes and here's a quick
health tip
tablespoon of apple cider vinegar
bragg's in a cup
of room temperature water ripe cake and
right before bedtime
help with weight loss help with your gut
unbelievable it gives you a good night's
sleep dude she wrote everything that's
troubling society right now
weight loss gut health digestion
complexion so much more
imagine i spent 10 years educating
myself
on the pathophysiology and the
pharmacology and the anatomy
when all i had to go was and now i just
solved
all the problems that are ailing society
why don't we just give this to everybody
and end this
you're not gonna believe what just
happened promise i am i go to get my flu
shot
don't do me wrong here and she goes all
right well do you want it in your left
or right arm i said
my left um but i have a long sleeve
shirt on
so i don't know if it's gonna pull up
all the way i might just have to take my
arm out if that's okay and she and
before i could even do that
she doesn't even answer me really she
doesn't give me an option she goes oh
that's okay this happens all the time no
issues
through she gives me the shot through
my shirt so now do i have like a piece
of
cotton in my bloodstream just floating
around
no this is not normal and you shouldn't
be doing this one you have to look at
where you're injecting
you have to see a clean surface you have
to clean it with a alcohol wipe in order
to disinfect the area
also you want to make sure you're not
injecting into a mold
already infected source like imagine
underneath the shirt she had
a big cellulitis and infection there and
abscess and now you're injecting into it
like you gotta visualize where you're
injecting number one number two to
answer your question you don't just have
cotton floating around in your body or
whatever material because
likely the needle penetrated the holes
of the fibers and didn't cut through the
fiber
and even if it did it wouldn't just be
floating in your body it would just be
in that area
and then your body would naturally push
it out well i don't think that's the
biggest problem i do think that's an
irresponsible way to give a flu shot if
that really happened i would like
probably complain about it because
that's not the norm there are 20 case
reports in the literature of people
whose colons have either exploded or
caught fire during surgery
the colon makes methane and some
hydrogen gas and if that combines with
oxygen
and a source of energy like a bovie or
a laser that can ignite a bovea is the
electrocautery tool that we sometimes
use instead of a scalpel to cut tissue
benefits of that is it actually cuts and
cauterizes at the same time so it
minimizes bleeding there's been a case
where
the surgeon caught fire and another
couple cases where the colon exploded
and the patient died
logically it all makes sense and it
could happen i'll just put it this way
i don't when i counsel my patients when
they're going for pre-op
screening and i counsel them on the
procedure they're gonna get
i don't usually include exploding colon
as part of the risks how can your body
replicate the feeling of falling from
high altitude in a nightmare
if you've never fallen like that this is
actually a really good and interesting
question so psychologists believe that
the fear of falling is actually an
evolutionary
or innate trait within us to actually
protect us so it's different from the
fear of heights which some people have
but almost every human and almost every
animal has the fear of falling they've
even tested this in
infants as young as like six months old
if they put them near a glass floor
that's a few feet up and then their
mothers call them
the infants will actually avoid the
glass floor or not come at all because
even at that age without the experience
of falling they innately know that it's
a dangerous thing asap science comes
through again with some accurate info
well done something i can add to this
conversation because i work in a
neonatology ward as a family medicine
doctor
one of the reflexes we test in babies is
called the moral reflex
it's kind of evil when you see us do it
when we essentially like
rapidly drop the baby you're not
actually making contact like the baby's
not falling
but you basically lower the baby really
quickly the baby kind of tries to grasp
on and save itself
because it has the innate survival
mechanism
known as the moro reflex so this is
something we are innately born with
another
species this is very evident is puppies
a newborn puppy you put them near stairs
they know not to go down their head they
don't just throw themselves down even
though
no one walked up to them and was like
hey these are stairs if you go down
gravity will go
click here for me and a mortician
partnering up watching six feet under or
check me out another day in the life in
my hospital on a coved ward
or unit or wing whichever you like as
always stay happy and healthy